happy Juneteenth Democrats on Capitol
Hill are celebrating the end of slavery
by pushing for reparations for the
great-great great-great grandchildren of
black slaves we will examine why that's
a terrible idea
then President Trump kicks off his bid
to make America great again again and
someone planted kiddie porn on Alex
Jones's infowar servers all of that and
more I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
so much to get to today but first let me
tell you about big token let me help you
make a little bit of money big token is
a new app that lets you share data about
yourself
your interests and your habits and then
you get paid for it this is the part you
are already sharing all of this data you
share an enormous amount of information
with tech companies already and they get
it for free they make a lot of money on
it you should also make some money on it
that's where big token comes in here's
how it works first you download the app
and you sign up for a free big token
account then you complete actions to
earn points and that can be anything
from answering surveys checking in to
locations just saying hey look I'm here
right now check to connecting your
social networks and more then you redeem
your points for rewards like cash and
gift cards or if you were a good person
you could donate your earnings to
charity but you'll probably go for the
cash in the gift cards you choose which
data you want to share with big token
then you get paid for it and those are
the two keys here you choose which data
are going to big token it's not like
they're just going to take your data you
get to pick then you get paid both very
important plus you get more points for
referring friends and family your data
is always secured on big token it is all
what you choose to share and then based
on that you'll be placed into specific
ad groups and brands will buy access to
those and everybody makes money most
importantly you get paid if you want to
start earning money from your data go to
the App Store Google Play search for big
token b.i.g Tok en that's one word
download the app and sign up but most
importantly make sure to use my referral
code Knolls canna wles so that when
everyone makes money and you make money
I get to make money too and keep my show
on the air so search big token in the
App Store go to Google Play wherever you
get your apps download the app use my
referral code Knolls que no wles to sign
up claim your data and get paid before
we get to reparations this is kind of
the big story right now it's happening
on Capitol Hill as we speak before we
get to that I just have to tell you
something it was an epiphany I had I
woke up in the middle of the night in a
cold sweat because I think I have solved
once and for all the immigration debate
in the United States so you remember
yesterday
Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez said that the Trump
administration's immigration policies
are like the Holocaust here's what she
said is running concentration camps on
our southern border and that is exactly
what they are they are concentration
camps and if that doesn't bother you I
don't I like we can have okay whatever
I'm gonna talk to the people that are
concerned enough with humanity to say
that we should not that never again
means something so you heard that she
said it's like concentration camps she
said it's just like never again which is
a direct reference to the Holocaust so
the Trump administration's immigration
policies are like the Holocaust but then
the other fresh face of the Democrat
Party
Rashidah Talib said that the Holocaust
gives her a calming feeling just if you
didn't two weeks ago or so we celebrated
or just it took a moment I think in our
country to remember the Holocaust and
there's you know this is kind of a
calming feeling I always tell folks when
I think of the Holocaust and a tragedy
followed cause so if the Trump
administration having immigration laws
is just like the Holocaust and the
Holocaust gives Democrats a calming
feeling the Trump administration's
immigration policies give Democrats a
calming feeling we've come to a national
consensus we don't need to talk about it
anymore that's it
we're doing good on the immigration
plans for it and Trump keep going full
steam ahead you have the support of the
fresh faces in the future of the
Democrat Party just I woke up as if with
a start I said there it is one of the
central issues in our country there are
some other issues going on in our
country now that we've solved
immigration we also have to move on to
the most important issue of the day
forget the economy forget peace abroad
forget the immigration forget our
national borders no the most important
issue of the day is reparations for the
great great great great grandchildren of
slaves 150 years after slavery was
abolished in the United States they're
holding hearings on this right now
on Capitol Hill why are they doing it
today today is June 10th and I think
some people don't know what Juneteenth
is either me this is like a geographic
issue some people have never heard of it
Juneteenth is a very important day in
the ending of slavery it's not the day
when slavery was abolished by the
Emancipation Proclamation that was
issued on September 22nd 1862 by
President Lincoln and it went into
effect January 1st 1863 it's it's not
the day that we exactly freed all of the
slaves it's not the day that we freed
all the slaves in the rebelling States
it's the day that slavery was abolished
in Texas so Texas was not a battleground
of the Civil War and so the Emancipation
Proclamation didn't have any effect
there and then on June 18th the Union
Army General Gordon Granger arrived at
Galveston Island with 2,000 federal
troops and he said federal law is the
law here now in Texas and he announced
the next day freedom for the slaves
that's Juneteenth
and this Juneteenth so many years later
a lot of Democrats are calling for
reparations for the descendants of black
slaves in the United States here's
Sheila jackson-lee
HR 40 is in fact is in fact the response
of the United States of America long
overdue slavery is the original sin
slavery has never received an apology
Sheila jackson-lee one of the dumbest
members of the US Congress which is
really saying something in the US
Congress the average IQ is about 50 and
she is a particularly egregious a member
of Congress she has come out and said we
need reparations for slavery because the
United States has never apologized for
slavery of course the United States has
apologized for slavery we fought a
bloody war where between 600 and 750
thousand Americans killed themselves to
answer for the question of slavery we
then had a civil rights movement and
then we had
a great society we had you know we had
these all these federal welfare programs
that we were trying to effect to you
know bring about some equality and
apologize for historical slavery so
obviously this is ridiculous
the leftist writer ton ez coats makes a
much better case for reparations the
typical black family in this country has
1/10 the wealth of the typical white
family black women died in childbirth
they're four times the rate of white
women and there is of course the shame
of this land of the free boasting the
largest prison population on the planet
of which the descendants of the enslaved
make up the largest share the matter of
reparations is one of making amends and
direct redress but it is also a question
of citizenship in HR forty this body has
a chance to both make good on its 2009
apology for enslavement and reject
fair-weather patriotism to say that a
nation is both its credits and it's
debits that if Thomas Jefferson matters
so to Sally Hemings that if d-day
matters so does black Wall Street that
if Valley Forge matters
so does Fort Pillow because the question
really is not whether we will be tied to
the some things of our past but whether
we are courageous enough to be tied to
the hold of them the case is basically
this that regardless of who's
responsible for slavery
regardless doesn't matter black people
do worse in America than other groups
they do worse then not not all other
groups there are some groups that do
worse specifically Native Americans for
instance but on the whole black people
in America have less money have higher
rates of crime lower educational
attainment outcomes they marry at lower
rates they have higher out of wedlock
birth they have higher rates of abortion
in the united air in new york city
rather 60% of black babies are aborted
more black babies are aborted than born
it's the most dangerous place for a
black person in new york is in his
mother's womb that that's terrifying
mean that's bad and so what Tanya Coates
is saying is regardless of who's
responsible for it
this is the fact you can't deny that
right now black people are doing worse
in America than other groups are that's
true what hit what he is saying is that
history is affecting black people today
and I actually agree with him I think
this is a pretty good case I mean just
speaking personally when I think of the
country
my ancestors helped to found America
four of them came over here on the
Mayflower they fought in I think every
American war John and Simon Knowles
fought at Bunker Hill John died of his
wounds there Simon Knowles was in
Washington's army was with him at Valley
Forge
George Cobb Knowles died at the battle I
think of Boyton plank road in the Civil
War they I just when I look back on the
history of America I see my family's
involvement in it and that gives me a
loyalty to the country real love of the
country a sense of responsibility toward
the country if my ancestors were dragged
here on slave ships I would have a very
different view of the United States and
that's it's not anybody's fault that's
that's just natural of course you would
if your if your ancestors are brought
here in Chains and suffered a systematic
oppression and enslavement for a hundred
years or 150 years you're going to have
a dismal or dim view of the history of
the country now maybe that's changed by
the fact that America fought a bloody
civil war to free the slaves and that
America has tried to live up to its own
greed over many years sure maybe that
changes your view of it but I totally
get the tiny hazy Coates argument
however codesys solution doesn't make
any sense the solution of reparations
for the descendants of slaves is totally
idiotic because I guess fundamentally
why it's wrong is because it's a Marxist
view so it offers a materialist view of
the world it offers this view of the
world that money solves all problems
that basically what ton easy Coates is
saying what all of these guys pushing
for reparations for slavery are saying
is that all problems stem from the
distribution of money and all problems
can be solved with the redistribution of
money that's obviously not true
I'm and actually the Great Society Lord
showed us this I mean the the Great
Society programs of LBJ the massive
welfare spending of the 1960s and 70s
showed us we threw money at the problem
and the problem didn't get solved the
problem didn't get any better actually
the problem just got worse it actually
ended up hurting the people it was
intended to help an example of this
outside of you know reparations for
slavery or anything like that is in
education spending for 40 years we
increased education spending inflation
adjusted by three hundred seventy five
percent guess what happened to test
scores nothing they didn't improve at
all
we threw money at the problem we kept we
threw more and more money at the problem
didn't do anything is the problem of
educational attainment didn't stem from
money and the redistribution of money
was not going to solve it with same
thing we increased welfare spending to
write historical racial wrongs to defeat
poverty they say we fought a war on
poverty and poverty one we actually
learned from the Moynihan report that
came out after the Great Society that we
ended up hurting the people that we
intended to help a crime rates increased
out of wedlock birth rates increased
abortion rates increased because there
were perverse government incentives for
the breakdown of the black family
nevertheless reparations remain very
popular among 20 20 Democrats so right
now currently supporting reparations you
have cory booker Kamala Harris Bernie
Sanders who Lee and Castro Liz Warren
Kirsten Gillibrand bado O'Rourke so many
I mean I think there probably 800 other
Democrats that we can't even name all of
those guys are supporting reparations
this is radical I mean this is not a
normal policy position to hold notably
Barack Obama who's a very left-wing
politician didn't hold this policy view
and Barack Obama obviously the first
black president Barack Obama said quote
I fear reparations would be used as an
excuse for some to say that we've paid
our debt and to avoid the much harder
work so what he's saying is actually
reparations wouldn't go far enough
it would give America the opportunity to
just cut a check and say okay
problems associated with slavery and Jim
Crow and lynchings and all of that
they've just been totally rectified now
we don't have to think about it anymore
actually I sort of agree with Barack
Obama on this that's ridiculous of
course that doesn't change history it
doesn't change the past and it doesn't
change the way that the past affects the
present so I hate to say it but I agree
with Barack Obama on reparations I also
agree with Mitch McConnell who makes the
point that reparations today money from
white people today to black people today
or whoever else they're going to try to
organize it is just incoherent yeah I
don't think reparations for something
that happened 150 years ago for whom
none of us currently living or
responsible is a good idea we've you
know tried to deal with our original sin
of slavery by fighting a civil war about
passing landmark civil rights
legislation we've elected an African
American president I think we're always
a work in progress in this country but
no one currently alive was responsible
for that and I don't think we should be
trying to figure out how to compensate
for it first of all it'd be pretty hard
to figure out who to compensate we've
had waves of immigrants as well who've
come to the country and experienced
dramatic discrimination of one kind or
another so no I don't think reparations
are a good idea totally makes sense he
actually makes the broader point which
is that yes black slavery was a
particularly egregious form of
oppression but other groups have faced
systemic oppression when we talk about I
mean obviously the question of lynching
and vigilante justice has been brought
up in this conversation about
reparations the largest mass lynching in
American history was against Sicilian
people in 1891 does that mean that we're
going to have some special federal
program for the descendants of Sicilian
people I asked in a leading way wouldn't
mind a little extra money no of course
not how about Jews how about any other
group the Irish Hispanics any
other group that's come to America has
also faced depression obviously not at
the level of a century or more of
chattel slavery but who are you to say
that their oppression doesn't demand a
little payback from the federal
government reparations don't make any
sense from all for all of those reasons
and most especially because money
doesn't just necessarily solve problems
because we're not fundamentally just
material beings we're not
Winston Churchill said that when great
forces are on the move in the world we
learned that we're spirits not animals
the destiny of man is not measured by
material computations materialism
Marxism is wrong that's not how the
world is it's a it doesn't take into
account suffering it doesn't take into
account what history means for the
present it doesn't take into account the
actual motivations of people which are
not primarily about money which are not
primarily material but beyond all of
that reparations will not achieve what
people want them to achieve it is Toth
it is just in practice totally
impracticable it's unclear who should
pay whom it's unclear where the money
comes from where the money is supposed
to go
so everybody acknowledges that slavery
is a particular moral evil and most of
the founders understood this as well
though they don't get any credit for it
but the case for reparations rests on a
basic ignorant about the fundamental
facts of slavery to put this into
context I think a lot of people think
that the United States was the chief
importer of slaves from West Africa not
true the United States imported at most
four to six percent of the African
slaves who came to the new world the
majority of those slaves went to Brazil
and South America and Central America
this is obviously not singularly an
issue about the United States it
affected the entire world it's not even
just about the West it's not even just
about the Western Hemisphere
it affected the entire world it still
affects the entire world there is
slavery today throughout Asia throughout
the Middle East it currently exists we
just ended it in the late or in the mid
to late nineteenth century also and this
is the part that people
explode slavery is not simply a racial
issue it's not simply white people had
black slaves ironically this is one of
these quirks of history that shows you
God must exist because it's so whimsical
and it's so ironic and you think there's
no way this could possibly be true
the first formally recognized slave
holder in America was black we'll
explain who it wasn't what it was but
first you and I we're never gonna agree
about it everything are we there's one
thing that we can all agree on that we
could all use more sleep I only got
about 17 hours of sleep last night it's
why I look so drowsy and tired but I got
17 hours of great sleep because now I
did I don't maybe not 17 hours but I
didn't get a great night's sleep last
night because of Bowland branch it's so
much more affordable than you think
you if you want to get a great sleep and
you want to do it the simplest way
possible change your sheets and don't
change them with those cheapo sandpaper
sheets that you buy down the street go
check out bold and branch everything
bowl and branch makes from bedding to
blankets is made from pure 100% organic
cotton which means they start out
supersoft they get softer over time you
can buy them directly from them so
you're paying wholesale prices I saw
this when I was getting married and I
had a registry you know luxury sheets
can cost a thousand dollars and they're
so expensive and I I don't know if
you've ever felt luxury sheets I've
gotten to stay at some nice hotels
sometimes luxury sheets are unbelievable
they make all the difference in the
world and I just thought there's no way
I can ever afford these boland brand
sheets are only a couple hundred bucks
they cut out the middleman goes straight
to you shipping is free you can try them
for 30 nights if you don't love them you
can send them back for a refund but
you're gonna love them you're not going
to send them back not a chance so there
is no risk no reason not to give them a
try to get started right now my
listeners get 50 bucks off your first
set of sheets at Boleyn branch com promo
code Michael mi CH AE L go to bol L and
branch comm today for 50 bucks off your
first set of sheets Bo ll and branch
comm promo code Michael do it right now
Boland branch comm promo code Michael
you're gonna love it this is one of the
great historical ironies that nobody
the first formally recognized slave
holder in the United States was not some
white southern bumpkin it was a black
guy
the first formally recognized slave
owner was a guy named Anthony Johnson he
was a black Angolan former farmer rather
he was captured in Angola by Arab slave
traders the Arab slave traders sold him
off he ended up in Virginia and he was a
slave in Virginia he was eventually
emancipated after his indenture was over
he was freed and he himself became a
successful farmer he also owned slaves
so he owned a black slave named John
case or and John case or felt that at a
certain point he should have been freed
he had committed his indenture his
servitude you know the the idea of
indentured servitude was you would you
would be a slave basically for a certain
period of time then you would be
emancipated and John case were felt that
he had served his sentence and should
have been emancipated and Anthony
Johnson the black Angolan farmer said no
you're my slave for life they took it to
court and a Virginia Court ruled that
Johnson owned John case or for life so
the question is are the black
descendants of Anthony Johnson a slave
owner entitled to reparations for
slavery doesn't make a whole lot of
sense does it
or the black descendants of John case or
the slave owned by Anthony Johnson
entitled to reparations from the black
descendants of Anthony Johnson so that
means that when we haven't reparations
for slavery some black descendants of
slave owners have to pay the reparations
to some black descendants of slaves is
that how are we gonna work that are we
gonna be taking DNA tests and
ancestry.com is gonna get hundreds of
millions of dollars in federal grants
just to figure out who was descended
from whom what if you're descended from
a black slave owner and a black slave
which does it cancel out or a white
slave owner in a black slave well how
are we going to adjudicate your
culpability today in 2019 for the sins
of your great-great-great grandfather's
or which great-great-great
great-great-grandfather also this
complicates it even more for the woke
social justice crowd it wasn't only
white people and black people who owned
slaves
Native Americans also held slaves and
Native Americans owned a lot of slaves
there were some black slave owners there
were a lot of white slave owners there
were a lot of white Native American
slave owners of the fight they were
called the Five Civilized tribes the
five major tribes talking about the
Cherokee the Choctaw those five tribes
adopted chattel slavery like the really
awful terrible worst form of slavery you
can imagine they adopted it in 1809 the
Cherokee had six hundred black slaves by
1838 so the time of the Trail of Tears
though Cherokee marched thousands of
slaves down the Trail of Tears ahead of
them or sent them by ship to the new
territory by 1860 on the eve of the
Civil War the Cherokee had 21,000 black
slaves those five major tribes owned
slaves black African slaves at the same
rate as southern whites now this gets
even more complicated because it's not
just that the Five Civilized tribes held
black slaves at the same rate as
southern whites and then slavery was
over and then that was it
because when the federal government
freed the slaves the Emancipation
Proclamation and the Thirteenth
Amendment
Juneteenth and all that when they freed
the slaves that didn't free the slaves
in the Indian territories because the
Indian territories were sovereign they
had their own territory they had their
own system of government they had their
own laws and they weren't bound by the
laws of the United States so actually
the Indians kept black slaves longer
than the federal than the United States
did now eventually the federal
government intervened here so the the
Five Civilized tribes did not free the
slaves on their own they the federal
government came in and forced them
basically to sign a treaty in 1866 and
one provision of that treaty was that
they free the slaves and this was a
sticking point in the negotiations but
eventually all of the tribes agreed to
it and so in 1866 a year after the Civil
War ended the Indians finally agreed to
free their slaves and abolish slavery so
are the great great great great
grandchildren of black slaves today
entitled to reparations from Native
American tribes not just the descendants
of Native Americans but
the actual sovereign tribes as they
exist today are they entitled to that
are we going to is the is this federal
commission that the Democrats want to
set up going to send a bill to the
Native American tribes for slavery for
holding slaves longer than even the
Americans did probably not that doesn't
really work well with the intersectional
victim pyramid does it what is the
conclusion from all of this it's an
obvious one you can't fix the past can't
do it
it's not that's why it's the past that's
the definition of the past you've only
got the present and you specifically
can't correct a past injustice with a
present injustice taking somebody's
property because of the sins of their
great-great great-great-grandfather's or
the sins of one of their great-great
great-great-grandfather's but not their
other great-great-great
great-grandfather and you've got if
you've got to basically come to some
sort of biologically determined
adversity suffering victimhood score and
then what do you find out you're 72%
victim so you only have to pay 28
percent of the reparations tax on that
what is it how on earth is this going to
be put into practice it's a total
injustice why are Democrats focusing on
this this is absurd even Barack Obama
thinks it's absurd very left-wing guy
for his black president the reason
they're focusing on this is because the
left has no present problems to focus on
things are too freakin good so they have
to relitigate slavery a hundred and
fifty years later why they can't run in
the economy the economy is going great
can't run on jobs we have record low
joblessness they can't run on war or
peace we've got relative peace abroad
pretty good foreign policy they can't
run what are they going to run up they
got nothing so they're trying to
re-litigate slavery and it's ridiculous
and it leads to these sort of
absurdities like you're seeing on
Capitol Hill today conservatives don't
need to run on those things because our
policies are working incredibly well and
they're very popular in the here and now
and that is why President Trump
officially has kicked off his campaign
to make America great again again last
night we're going to keep making America
great
and then we will indeed Keep America
great
[Applause]
better than ever before we're gonna keep
it better than ever before and that is
why tonight I stand before you to
officially launch my campaign for a
second term as president okay so we all
knew this was happening it's no big
surprise that he's announcing his
campaign the campaign never really ended
he's he's done rallies throughout his
presidency this is true of other
presidents - I mean so it doesn't seem
like a huge moment except there was a
massive crowd there in Orlando Florida
it everyone is super excited he's just
it was visually a very good start to the
campaign and it had one of the most
beautiful moments of recent political
memory you're watching this on CNN CNN
has to cover it this is this is the news
and within six minutes of the rally
starting you hear a chant begin as
spontaneously from the crowd that says
CNN sucks
CNN sucks you can hear it here and then
what do you think CNN does they got a
cutaway
this was our chance to reclaim our
government all right we've been watching
the president kick off his re-election
bid he's been on stage for about six
minutes oh yeah is that right CNN so
that way you're telling me you
interrupted all of your programming so
that you could cover six minutes of the
rally I don't know about that usually
you'd have to cover around twenty
minutes thirty minutes of the rally but
they start almost from the beginning
start CNN sucks Trump turns around he's
got a grin on his face from ear to ear
and then within a minute of that
happening CNN cuts away okay well yeah
you've heard that all right that's
enough enough of that now go away also I
mean show me the lie this is obviously
what the crowd said is just objectively
true and it reminds you why people are
really fired up were fired up about all
of these issues were fired up about
immigration were fired up about the
economy were fired up about America you
know keep loving America loving the
country keeping the nation keeping our
sovereignty making America great again
we love all of those things and we
really really hate being lied to
it drives us crazy when these guys unzip
their flies on CNN and then they tell us
it's raining we hate that and when they
tell us not to believe our lying eyes we
hate that we don't like them they're
dishonest they're they're just dishonest
people and they don't like this country
very much and they make that clear day
after day and we're sick of it so it was
a great moment then President Trump gets
to all the classic points of what this
campaign is gonna be about with your
help with your love and your devotion
and with your drive we are going to keep
on working we are going to keep on
fighting and we are going to keep on
winning winning winning
we are one movement one people one
family and one glorious nation under God
and together we will make America
wealthy again we will make America
strong again
we will make America safe again and we
will make America great again that's
great obviously all the classic points
very popular and it's exactly the
opposite of what the Democrats want to
do Joe Biden says the first thing he's
going to do is take away the tax cuts so
Trump wants to make America wealthy
strong safe great what a Democrats want
to do they make it want to make it less
wealthy they want to take wealth away
from you they want America to be less
strong not to project strength overseas
to reduce our military reduce our
military spending they don't care if for
America to be safe they want totally
open borders and they don't want to
deport any criminals and they want
sanctuary cities for criminals who spit
in the face of our laws and they don't
want America to be great they don't
think America was ever great to begin
with Andrew Cuomo sitting governor of
New York he said during a speech he said
America was never that great to begin
with that's what they believed Trump is
doing exactly the opposite which is
great and he's also doing something that
Republicans haven't really done before
he goes at the Democrats throat he goes
at the left throat we'll see how in a
second but first I've got great news for
you we are taking our backstage show
live on the road argost 21st to the
terrace theater in Long Beach California
it's gonna be super fun ben shapiro
daily wire god-king jeremy boring the
lord of the multiverse Andrew Klavan and
best of all little ol me yours truly
will be live on stage discussing the
winners and losers of politics and pop
culture and doing our best to answer
your burning questions from the audience
tickets go on sale to the public this
Friday but only daily wire subscribers
get presale tickets s today through
Thursday you can do it time is running
out though do it right now subscribe get
your tickets today come join us for a
fabulous and fantastic event much much
more to get to we got to get to how
left-wing wackos presumably planted
kiddie porn on Alex Jones a server what
it means for our country what it means
for conservatism but first go to Daley
wire.com we'll be right back with a lot
more
so President Trump is hitting all the
right notes this rally this kickoff for
the campaign went off without a hitch
most importantly he's going at the
left's throat he is not afraid to get
down in the muck with them listen to how
he describes the left in America
[Applause]
opponents are driven by hatred prejudice
and rage they want to destroy you and
they want to destroy our country as we
know it not acceptable it's not going to
happen this is fabulous this is great
this is something Trump has done his
entire career is he's nice to people as
long as they're nice to him it takes us
to an extreme he's sometimes nice to Kim
jong-un if Kim jong-un is nice to him
but the minute someone goes after him
he goes after them twice as hard the
minute someone says hey Trump you're a
racist because you're a racist you're a
double triple awful racist
hey Trump you're not successful you're a
total loser you're an idiot you're a
failure and you're a shame to your
family and he just clobbers them he
doesn't take any guff from nobody I mean
that talk about really channeling a
classic piece of advice for New Yorkers
he he goes so hard just think about what
the left has been doing yesterday
Alexandria Ocasio Cortez said that if
you oppose open borders you are
basically Hitler you are a Nazi if you
don't think that we should have totally
open borders in America Alyssa Milano
and many other celebrities many other
left wingers have said that the magg
ahead make America great again that
phrase that hat is the same as a KKK
hood leftist voices from the mainstream
media to academia to elected politicians
have called for political violence
against conservatives this is not
hyperbole Maxine Waters a very prominent
member of Congress did this and then
double down she did it twice now in the
old days how did the GOP and
conservatives used to handle it
when the left would call us racist
bigoted sexist awful the worst people in
the world you should probably get
violent with them how did the GOP used
to handle that here's John McCain
typifying the old-school GOP response
during the 2008 campaign we're scared of
an obama presidency you know I'll tell
you why I'm concerned about you know
someone that you know cohorts with
domestic terrorists such as Ayers I have
to tell you he is a decent person and a
person that you do not have to be scared
as a president United States now I just
I just now look I I I gotta ask you a
question
I don't not believin I can't trust Obama
III have read about him and he's not
he's not he's a he's an Arab he is not
no no ma'am no ma'am he's a he's a he's
a decent family man citizen that I just
happened to have disagreements with on
fundamental issues and that's what this
campaign is all about he's not thank you
now John McCain could have said no he's
not an Arab but he is a danger to this
country his views and his policies will
damage America he'll steal people's
health care he'll destroy the greatest
health care system in the world he will
raise your taxes he'll destroy the
economy he will create eight years of
joblessness he will divide America he
will continue to do which is all things
that he did he could have said that but
he keep him but John McCain couldn't
leave it there and say no he's not an
Arab but he's a he's a pretty bad hombre
no he had to say he's a decent man he's
a good man
oh the left-wing that calls us evil and
racist and bigoted and terrible the
worst people on earth
those guys they're okay they're good
guys they're good guys so if they're
good guys then I guess we should elect
them that that's a bad strategy and
president Trump is saying no listen
left-wing if you want to play nice with
me and you want to be elevated and you
want to say say that we're decent people
and you're decent people and we just
have disagreements I'm willing to do
that but if you're gonna call me a not
senior gonna call my supporters Nazis in
half of this country Nazis then I'm
gonna say that you are hateful
prejudiced and fueled by rage which by
the way is true this is
working strategy we the RNC just
reported the RNC now is the Trump
campaign the RNC raised a record twenty
four point eight million dollars in just
24 hours more than a million dollars an
hour after this kickoff Joe Biden he
raised six point three million dollars
on his first day and that was a record
haul Trump raised four times that
massive win and that means the strategy
is working it means we shouldn't back
off the strategy he's absolutely right
to do it we would all like - we'd all
like to live in the nice Trump universe
where Trump is nice to people and people
are nice to Trump and but that's the
right attitude people say he's cruel and
mean and needlessly aggressive he's not
needlessly aggressive he's going to
treat you how you treat him we can't
have a society where half the country
treats the other half like absolute
mongrel swine Nazi hateful awful people
and then those of us who are being
attacked and assailed and smeared have
to just say okay that's fine we'll take
it you guys are okay you do what you
want to do no we're not going to do that
if they're gonna do that to us we're
gonna push back and do it to them and
it's gonna get ugly and gross until they
realize that hmm the other side isn't
going to unilaterally disarm this is a
not a nice way to have a civil society
maybe we'll elevate the rhetoric a
little bit but it's getting really nasty
I mean someone apparently has now sent
Alex Jones kiddie porn to frame him as
some kind of pedophile and ship him off
to jail headline in the Connecticut Post
says quote when you know you know Alex
Jones you know is there shirtless
vitamin salesman he's think it's the
kind of conspiracy minded radio host
very entertaining radio host a headline
in the Connecticut Post quote lawyers
for Sandy Hook families say Alex Jones
sent them child porn let me ask you
something does that make any sense
Alex Jones is being sued by people and
so he would send them like the most
illegal thing you can possibly possess
that could send him away to prison for
life doesn't seem to make a whole lot of
sense so that the headline isn't true
the there was child pornography that was
sent and it was delivered by the
Infowars and Alex Jones wasn't sent to
the family to send to their lawyers and
wasn't sent from Jones it actually was
they basically asked for these troves of
emails from Infowars Infowars just
turned over all of the emails and some
emails that had been sent to Infowars
included graphic images of child
pornography so what it appears is that
what someone was doing was planting
child pornography on the Infowars email
servers and email addresses it seems to
me there's no way that Alex Jones knew
about this if he did if he did know that
there were there was child pornography
on there he would never have sent he
would never have given those emails to
his adversaries lawyers what you've done
would have destroyed it or he would have
refused to turn over the documents also
I suppose a legal but obviously a lot
better than just turning over a bunch of
child pornography so I guess it's
possible you never you know never say
never it's possible that Alex Jones is
the most incompetent pedophile in the
history of sex crimes probably unlikely
or more likely someone is playing a
particularly nasty trick on Alex Jones
they want to ruin his life they want to
send him and people who work with him to
prison forever and this plays on this
theme that we're looking at that we're
seeing this fueled by rage nasty hateful
spiteful the left wants to ruin
conservatives lives they want to work
they want to ruin Kyle Cash's life they
want you they want to ruin everybody
every conservatives life some sicko is
willing to deal one to deal in kiddie
porn just to score political points and
then to send it to a shirtless vitamin
salesman because they don't like his
politics or something they're gonna send
it to this guy because they think this
guy is such a great threat to the
country saying people didn't naturally
have homosexual feelings I'm not even
getting into it quite frankly I mean
give me a break people I don't like the
water to turn the friggin frogs gay do
you understand that
Sears crap I'm sick of being social
engineer it's not funny I gotta say he
says like some of the craziest things
but I get such a kick out of him he's
light an amazing broadcaster and that
guy you're willing to deal in child
pornography and try to frame a guy send
him to prison for life because he bangs
a table and says the frogs are gay
you're sick
something has gone sick in your mind in
your ideology if you do that because
you'd like don't like his politics or
something Hollywood celebrities Debra
Messing so happy congratulating Harvard
for ruining an 18 year old kid's life
because he said offensive and racial
things simply for shock value and he was
16 years old
journalists encouraging big technology
companies to prevent other content
creators that they disagree with from
making money from getting their voices
out there deep platforming not just you
to its Facebook its patreon payment
process is trying to stop conservatives
from ever being able to make a
livelihood ruin their lives
this Jones thing just one particularly
egregious example of the left hating the
right you can't have a country like that
for very long what's it's like when a
husband fights with his wife you're in a
fight with your spouse you're
disagreeing about something and you're
just trying to score points on each
other and you did this why did this and
you did that and then you do I'm gonna
do this then and how does that end you
still have to live with the person
you're married to the person it's half
of your flesh over there ostensibly you
still love each other you like each
other you've got some bonds holding you
together it's the same thing for a
country you still have to live together
is how is that gonna how is this gonna
end in America if half the country says
that if you don't support open borders
you're a Nazi half the country wants to
ruin the other half of life it doesn't
go both ways finally President Trump is
fighting back on behalf of the right but
it doesn't go both ways this is a
problem of the left doing this to the
right can't have a country like that for
very long that's not you know this this
actually brings up a
a great piece I read yesterday I highly
encourage you all to read it in first
things it was by a writer named
Elizabeth Corrie and she was talking
about the very little-known political
philosopher Michael Oakshott and it was
on this question of what is conservatism
what are we doing what is conservatism
about and the thesis was that true
conservatism requires recognizing the
world's beauty the question is what is
conservatism if I asked you on the
street
what is conservatism maybe you would say
it's free markets or it's a strong
military or it's Christian values or
it's low taxes what what is it
would you say it's that it's low taxes
and a strong military is that
conservatism that doesn't seem like all
it is this philosopher Michael Oakshott
says conservatism isn't any of those
things that conservatism is actually a
disposition rather than an ideology it's
not it's it's more a sensibility a way
of engaging with the world and looking
at the world and behaving it's not about
low taxes per may I mean maybe of course
it may be it implies low taxes or
certain values but it's more about just
the way that you behave he writes or she
writes talking about his philosophy the
disposition entails above all an
inclination to enjoy what there is to be
enjoyed rather than to seek for what is
not there you know the left is so
furious they don't enjoy anything they
don't laugh they don't have fun they
don't we live in like the greatest time
ever in the history of the world they
are miserable and some conservatives let
themselves be miserable all the time too
now we got to fight back we got to we we
have to stop them from totally
destroying the country we have to wage
certain battles but that's only
sometimes we also have to enjoy what we
have or else what's the point of it it's
not just about the fights it's not just
about the battles it's not just about
what is lost it's a there is some
pleasure in it this is this is one of
the simple joys of being right you know
we talked about the Western Canon and
liberal education how important it is
how important we need we need good
education and to remember our history
how often do we read those books we talk
about how old movies are so much better
than new crappy movies how often do we
watch the old movies and enjoy them we
talk about civil society how great it
was
when they were all these voluntary
organizations the Lions Club the Kiwanis
Club the PTA the boys gets how often do
you join those and go to those and
participate in those we talk about the
importance of a nation how often do we
engage with our fellow countrymen do we
really feel that we have some bonds to
them still you know we need to give the
left a taste of their own medicine and
we need to show them the stakes of what
they're doing and we need to stop them
from their path of complete destruction
but over the long haul
the only coherent conservatism is a
conservatism that actually engages with
and enjoys all of those things that we
say are worth conserving that's our show
got more to get to we'll do it tomorrow
in the meantime I'm Michael nose this is
the Michael Nolt show I'll see you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show Alexandria
occasional core text says arresting
illegal immigrants is like the Holocaust
because she's an ignoramus but there is
someone partying just like it's 1938 and
guess what it's not president the
Donnell I'll talk about it on the Andrew
Clavin show I'm Andrew Clavin